[Applaudissements]
hélas j'interprète tous les jours
francis cabrel et là j'aurai en lui
pouvait nous faire du coup de francis
cabrel alors attendez je réfléchis à la
chanson que je vais m'orienter
bonjour messieurs mais comment je vais
pas vous faire fois sur le jeu je vais
vous faire maxime le forestier par
coralie l'habitude de nous joue des
tours nous qui pensions que notre amour
avait une santé de fer chaud dès que
c'est sur la route ce sera posé sur la
musique et sur mes vers l teinte bien
les feuilles d'automne où vous n'étiez
pas né vous non je suis abonnée
j'appelle la wii de chez rim
c'est un style une chanson sur l'usure
du couple alors le savez la france a
déjà commencé c'est l'usure de tonnes
[Applaudissements]